the French tradition of integration has
frayed to feel that we are fresh and we
are equal the fifth Republic's hopes for
liberté egalité a fraternity have been
dashed its prime minister has admitted
the unthinkable and aparte de da de yong
sushi on it Nick he sail and [ __ ] and
it would be nice a year-round playground
of the pampered you la vie on its
impoverished offspring tucked away two
miles up and industrialized Valley major
denim OTA is in charge of police
operations here the main issues we face
here is uh drugs and a lot of
unemployment and we've got some mixed
social and crime issues here so it's a
good cocktail for you know people to
ridiculous and all that self
since being designated a priority
security zone two years ago Larry an has
been targeted with extra police and
intelligence resources to fight crime
and radicalization unpredictable
roadblocks slow down the movement of
drugs and weapons we stop diversity
burst up here and we control with an
alarm in uniform and we are recipe for
Asia they carry drug this is an
uncompromising approach isn't this
overkill men with side arms with machine
guns no I don't think so first you to
see machine gun because we are on a high
alert after the terrorist attack in
Paris so we need to adapt or weapons to
the situation we carry this operation
with a lot of forced to to stabilize the
situation and say people we are here for
your security in October we carry out an
operation of here because on the first
roll you've got a morir an hour drive by
drugs like like McDonald's but you you
just have my runner so that's why we
call this operation she'd drive because
[ __ ] is the name of marijuana in France
and we carry out an operation here and
during our investigation we found
weapons miss a Wesen beretta and
grenades and the rifle 6.62 and ak-47
ammunition no go areas do not exist in
France but this isn't somewhere where
armed officers feel comfortable that I
don't want to stay here love okay
so like that why yes we go look at and
scroll you know throw Serena King yeah
what doing here the sword bonfire a
nearby estate gets a visit from the
mobile johnd armory elite reinforcements
after the attacks on police in Paris
they have been warned that they could be
jihadi targets this isn't quite a war
zone but it's obvious that law and order
are not welcome here intended for you do
you think yeah because you're here
because you're filming so I think that
hey we're here listen drum it's our
territory social workers have been
drafted in to protect youngsters from
jihadi propaganda NSA documents also one
of occlusion Su Su Su Su Su sila the
apoco vida loca chica Jesus I insist
upon call problem you see whatever the
optimism on the ground the authorities
now see jihadi radicalization as a major
and growing threat so much so that the
government has launched an Internet
campaign often as horrific as the
Islamist propaganda it's fighting
they'll tell you sacrifice yourself for
us and you'll be defending a just cause
in reality you'll discover hell on earth
and you'll die alone far from home
some of the youngsters are radicalized
by the internet through the internet to
programs but it should not be
overestimated others they are the
majority that radicalized because they
are in contact with so-called creatures
with no official authority or whether
they are Islamic Authority or legal
authority and that's our main concern
because we see that lots of the
youngsters going abroad that are
radicalized they actually didn't go to
the prior rooms of the mesquite they
didn't attend the official rituals they
just were apart from the society and
from the Muslim community as well one
victim of personalized radicalization is
this man son together with the man who
brainwashed him he traveled to Syria to
fight in the ranks of Islamic state
modulus le pasa trata de li SI tratta
casually cct desire recipes a decision
Rock City dificil de lo de la firma
salir por la may la parte para para SE
peterka salon contro Calif inner or me
I'm Oladipo c'est par phir SE SI para SE
parler de la loire go to my dear Papa
circuit and now the French Prime
Minister has made a staggering admission
about the state of his nation la hora
gas E&P real men rega to secure 0 ke
onda min sangeeta an apartheid
territorial social ethnic ki sair a
posi- Toby la media social okay else
addision le discrimination cotillion
pass corona pallu Bonin famille la
pelicula poopoo en paz groaning from LA
I on this area has just been designated
1 of 64 official ghettos in France that
means ultimately that the French
government has given up on the great
Republic
dream that all French people are the
same and that they all come essentially
from the same culture the problem is
what will happen to the Lost Children of
the Republic in much of nice young
Muslims say they do feel isolated je
suis go super school rod real bad the
pillar to developers now found rubashka
Roja Victoria sure I pay telemedicine ok
reports villa for sample jamel the debt
methods on tf2 10 wanted a book were
inseparable scale easy for reverse
getting dizzy [ __ ] me yes it's a fair
measure passes our goddess of Fortune
2220 consents with the pd's on pou moi
Bruce on preferences sea lamprey stock
purchase real antique adidas Oct culito
statement is a true multi judwaa 2 Rho
gamma epsilon moves on la francaise
cusco city don't know
across from a drug den in Larry on this
is the region's first mosque built and
paid for with local donations and no
help from the French state we have to
think and to be clever and to look for
the future so the future for our
children is to open everything to feel
that we are French and we are equal many
here believe that France is
well-intentioned refusal to recognize
cultural differences between its
citizens risks in fact entrenching
radicalism so leaders are striving to
teach a traditional and peaceful version
of Islam do you know young people who've
gone to Syria to Iraq to to fight jihad
I have I met bishounen ki KI actual moon
a lava surely rencontre ECT Cal Cal the
cafe a UK correct mr. polska amantani
again rip to a dog sharply extra frisky
little party is dong Jesse drunken trace
on Papa a SE sont toujours de point
interrogation pony y le duela a yella
project wat de la Frankia Gandhi
official depa soprano in a form the new
owner password coming from the CC a
lesion Patek nishant account his own
down the process you see there bokeelia
la vie amala was mom kept our essays on
pokey Swan a spear a book it's rob
pre-dawn santo beyond they are preset
receive the compound kill ed junkies on
the wallet from television met in a year
c difficile de la vie Takaful easily or
circular method is a year no metal my
antenna pre-owned village a year a rest
dose of lockers no Cecile indoctrination
has reached into the low teens this
woman's 15 year old son went berserk
when she prevented him from traveling to
Syria to fight
yo SE tu papa deja mon fils ma con le
numéro de téléphone j2 marque y les
appelle pose a vaca de aza see pally so
fast a pas de Gama sadism elimina me
Kirksey phobic Limina Jana Vickers y
despues se fait sur la fila iphone / ha
ha's otra mejilla / mon fils led jepara
we see now a new pattern of people that
are radicalized in france and they don't
want to go abroad because they know us
as soon as a go broad they will have
average temple in a way and they will be
marked as radicalized so if they don't
travel to these countries they are not
marked so they keep going in the ticket
and I'm more concerned about the one
that have not gone broad than the one
that I've gone abroad the same fears
Great Britain where in contrast the
front cultural differences have been
celebrated the both nations have
identified a problem but a solution
eludes the ones great colonial powers